[Musique]
je préfère c'est un cadeau de fin
d'année pour les parisiens et peut-être
au-delà des parisiens pour tous les
français corps aussi bien les
marseillais que les bordelais clemi
lyonnais viennent un jour ou l'autre
visiter notre dame et ses abords donc
pour eux vous allez prévu une série de
parking d'abord ici effectivement le
danger de paris a pris sa décision
maintenant en définitive sur le principe
de la construction d'un parc de
stationnement double le premier sous le
parvis pour 250 voitures de tourisme le
deuxième sous le score de l'archevêché
en attendant caen 26 auto caen et deux
cent dix huit heures de tourisme humaine
étant qu'il est question de ce parc dé
stationnement
mais il a fallu d'abord régler le
problème des fouilles nous sommes ici au
coeur historique de paris et il est
évident qu'il y avait des vestiges qu'on
ne pouvait pas sacrifier en creusant le
parc
il fallait donc d'abord s'occuper de ces
vestiges je suis jolie j'ai l'impression
depuis très longtemps on creuse sous
d'autres dames devant notre-dame autour
de notre dame
oui il ya un très long temps lui-même au
xviie siècle pour la construction de la
fontaine et surtout en 1847
on a donc retrouvé à peu près toutes les
étapes de notre histoire et de la
préhistoire aussi oui et on retrouve
l'enceinte gallo-romaine dans le
chantier de 1965 dirigée par monsieur
fleury et en 1847 en a trouvé les
substitutions de l'ancienne église
saint-etienne élise qui a précédé notre
dame de paris
le parti devant notre-dame sont à peu
près ici oui peut être même construit ou
bien on ne sait pas encore exactement et
toute cette partie ci qui est la partie
la plus intéressante sera protégé
conserver et on pourra descendre dans
cette crypte et voir les vestiges je
l'espère le principe d'aménagement qui
est retenu map non c'est faire un
aménagement global espoirs de
l'archevêché sud de notre adam épargné
proprement dit construire là dessus
ces deux parcs de stationnement et puis
une crypte archéologique pour mettre les
feux et
il reproduit des feuilles à la
disposition du public pour le faire
valoir nous avons ici trouver des choses
extrêmement intéressante
est ce le parvis dans un deuxième temps
rendre le parvis au public c'est à dire
pousser le plus loin possible la
circulation automobile dans l'ouest dans
la préfecture de police oui peut-être en
supprimant le poteau le compte doubler
toute façon condamné il est usé il faut
le remplacer
or on va aménager et on va commencer
sous peu les travaux de la voie express
rive gauche
à ce moment là le problème du poteau
double se posera il sera certainement
déplacer de façon à faciliter le report
de la circulation automobile
[Musique]